warning that there are some images of a
dead boy in a body bag
and people in distress that you may find
disturbing
they just managed to resuscitate a
patient who's crashed
kovit is tearing through india and every
hospital ward
and they're still not winning the fight
to get on top of this enormous surge
he has collapsed and we have revived him
and now we are
managing him they're low on medicines
they're low on staff
and they're low on oxygen
okay on the sos number that 400 just
lock it saying that we are desperately
in need
in less than one hour and our pressures
are dropping doctor summit ray spends
the entire time we're with him in the
intensive care unit
caring for his dangerously ill patients
whilst also ringing round for oxygen
and right now levels are perilously low
it's a constant struggle
till last night 2 30 at night i was
struggling for oxygen and again
from the morning
[Music]
they're doing what they can but
sometimes it's just
not enough
this man is one of the many who didn't
make it
they're told international aid is
arriving the government insists it's
sorting
but on the ground the situation is just
as dire
the problem for this hospital and so
many others in the capital and across
india is that
this crisis does not seem to be abating
just yet
in fact if anything it's getting worse
because the health workers
the doctors and nurses are getting more
and more ground down
and still scrambling from hour to hour
to try to get oxygen for their patients
it is not about being let down it is it
is a collapse
you know they we do not have time to
feel sorry for somebody
else we are losing patience here
and it is not a hidden factor it is
there
everybody knows it the government knows
it the administration knows it everybody
knows it
[Music]
is so crowded the doctors and nurses
barely have room to move between beds
the only way to get into this unit is if
a patient dies
outside the hospital there are vehicles
banked up in front
of the emergency department with people
inside
struggling to breathe waiting to get a
bed
to get help many are in a terribly weak
state by the time they get here
and have often traveled around several
hospitals before one will accept them
[Music]
in the emergency room itself every space
is taken
they're pushed up in corners and
receiving treatment
seated in the waiting area nishant
rushed his father in here the day before
and now their friends are busy scouring
delhi to buy oxygen
hospital might run out anytime they
don't have any basic support of oxygen
they might turn out in few hours and
there are patients holding here
the yesterday the emergency voltage was
closed for no more patient because it
was full this was also full and bed is
also full
finally dr summit ray gets the news he's
been waiting for the auction has just
reached
it's a huge relief after working the
phones
for most of the night and most of the
day
how many more minutes have you got left
i think we had 20 25
i don't know actually we don't know we
could have shut down any time to tell
you honestly
the oxygen he's fought so hard for
arrives with a police guard
he's bought his patients a few hours but
that's all
[Music]
india's covert crisis is like being hit
by a massive
earthquake he argues and the country
needs a significant government and
worldwide response
if there is any help that we can get
from the west from any other countries
is not
just oxygen it is like any
major disaster what happens in a major
disaster in our earthquake
teams of doctors nurses hospitals
hospital beds come in then this
build up a hospital from scratch quickly
like a major that is what we has to
happen
there are some signs the virus may be
leveling off in delhi
but with hospitals so overwhelmed still
the capital
and india are not out of the coronavirus
catastrophe yet
alex crawford sky news delhi